look at look at what you're telling me
you're basically saying to me it's
better that you go or we will kill you
ultimately it's going to end bad thank
you good so you're basically asking for
a race war no I'm not asking that's what
we're going to get don't be sh you've
been very that's what we're going to get
I feel nothing for you I just pity you
should you you should P to yourself you
should you you should P to yourself
you're the one covered in microphones
making money off videos how do you not
make money I don't I don't I don't I
don't make a penny coming here where you
get I I don't make a penny I used to do
Uber and I actually do some other work
yeah I'm not coming I don't smoke
cocaine and go prostitutes yeah I don't
do that c a Muslim you eat Curry yes you
eat Curry Kebab yeah all this stuff you
go to a Muslim countries you go and get
yourself T to look like us and then
you're come here complain about us we
got the recipe your recipe of
disaster did you guys know the
definition of emergency is a serious
situation that requires immediate action
imagine your loved ones under Rubble in
earthquake or bombs being dropped in
Gaza or in men or in Afghanistan where
there's an earthquake brother and
sisters we're working with one um to get
immediate relief to those who are in
need please go to the link and donate
whatever you can inshallah and let this
be a that use for your use there for
your brothers and sisters when they
needed you you said that you don't want
any shape or color of Muslims yes okay
what do you mean by that like I mean any
you you don't want them like I don't
want English people white English people
who become Muslims you don't want
English become Muslims okay need to go
as well Al so anyone that accept Islam
with us should go with us yes okay where
where do we go to countless Muslim
countries okay so where about the ones
that are born here uh that doesn't make
any difference so they they should go as
well okay so where would you say this
idea ideology is coming from cuz it's
obviously an extreme ideology it's just
from history so history so history
teaches that people want to be with
their own kind yeah and history
shouldn't repeat theirself like Nazi
Germany like what happened in Congo
Congo where NE Leon um King leopo II
killed 10 million congales so history
shouldn't repeat their so you want to go
back to history yeah so I'm asking you
Belgium shouldn't be in Congo no no
exactly but what I'm saying is they do
if you look at it most of your like
we're gonna go down that route your
governments are the one that's
infiltrating these countries stealing
the resources killing Millions okay good
so what government is our mutual enemy
okay so the best thing you can do to
piss off the government is to leave
because they use you to attack us not
really how do they use us they come we
we are not when we're even here
islamophobic okay so the the point I'm
seeing is this like fil why can't you
ever just
let me tell you why I can but you know
what it is your ideology is so dangerous
that I would rather educate the people
that are watching this yeah it's
dangerous can please sorry the reason
I'm doing this is because not that look
I can do this off camera the reason I'm
doing on camera is so that if there is
someone out there like you who might
take their ideologies teing it with
click no no no no no no you're just
clickbait you live off the a I don't I
wouldn't I wouldn't say so because your
ideology is so dangerous that there
might be someone out there who is going
to go out and attack a Muslim or vice
versa I don't want to attack you I just
want to leave you you don't but there
are people that made you like we've seen
yes but if you leave then they can't
attack you no but that's the point is
that look at look at what you're telling
me you're basically saying to me it's
better that you go or we will kill you
ultimately it's going to end bad thank
you good so you're basically asking for
a race war no I'm not asking you that's
what we're going to get don't be shy
you've been very that's what we're going
to get yeah no that's what you want no
nobody wants it you do want that okay
we're telling you by having Mass Muslim
immigration that's the only result so
only Mass Muslim immigration so not the
Romanians who are Christians yeah I
don't want anyone okay okay so but no
but you said Mass Muslim immigration
what about the Romanian Christians mass
Catholic immigration before good so you
got a problem with them as well yes okay
good so you got a problem with everybody
because they're against our values okay
what's your values English values what's
your English values 100 years ago you
you know English History not really not
that much yeah so tell
me your parents and your mother used to
dress up like a Muslim woman your father
had the values of a Muslim if you go to
your grandparents and tell them about
lgbqt they'll tell you we got nothing to
do with it he was a he's a liberal
Democrat second your father's father's
father did not live by lgbqt laws they
did not follow these things they were
dressed up modestly they didn't believe
sex before marriage they they had
Traditional Values liberal English
people laid the groundwork for all this
one second so what I'm saying is this
they were closer to us than they are to
you from the way they dress to the way
they
think check it there's a video actually
in the 1900s you will see a video of
British woman dressed up in hijab you
would see them dressed up decently they
had Traditional Values no sex before
marriage none of that stuff not n no not
nuns there's a video that shows London
or north of the UK look at the
population they were just there I
believe being moderate is not showing so
much skin your great grandparents were
had more common values with us than
Victorian values that's why we need to
go back to but Victorian values are
nothing like Islam okay do you do you
what's your um view on homosexuality I
think it's wrong and why do you think
it's wrong because God you know marriage
is between a man and woman to create
okay baby and have babies okay good
that's what it's for so the idea that
and and and David Cameron a conservative
MP legalizes gay marriage yeah and that
he's trying to Gaslight the population
to think that's that makes sense that
has meaning two men can get married has
any meaning okay that's fine it doesn't
mean anything okay what about
transgender so we're dealing with
conservative politicians that are
demented okay and they want to destroy
our society okay good so what about
legalizing gay marriage what about
giving young kids puberty Brokers yes of
course that's you're against who are the
who are the ones that are in the
Forefront fighting this the Muslims
really yes and you guys are right behind
us we are the ones who protesting School
in our country for our for your your yes
for your values that you countries are
so backward you haven't even we Muslims
are fighting you'll you'll be going
through this LGBT in a thousand years
that's fine but what I'm saying is we
Muslims are fighting for your values
that you let go off we don't need your
help thanks no no but we do my friend my
friend I'm telling you I don't want your
help my friend Elon mus you I don't want
talking musk his son if he can't fight
it what hope is there for so what I'm
what I'm saying is that we as Muslims
are the ones at the Forefront fighting
this agenda okay so you actually need us
you definitely need us the only thing
you just want to use like a hole in the
head exactly see you you need us we need
you like a hole in the head you need us
like a hole in the head what does that
mean do you mean to put a hole in my
head or do you mean like a that's a bit
of like witty English word what does it
what does it mean like does it mean we
don't need want a hole in the head oh
okay you don't want a hole in the head
you look you look like you look like you
want to put a hole in my head I don't
want to put yeah you do no you can't you
you can't I nothing to you yeah no you
should you you should P to yourself you
should you you should P yourself you're
the one covered in microphones making
money off videos how do you not make
money I don't I don't I don't I don't
make a penny coming here you get I I
don't make a penny I used to do Uber and
I actually do some other work yeah I'm
not I don't smoke cocaine and go prostit
yeah I don't do that yes yeah exactly
exactly yeah you're Muslim you're c a
Muslim you eat Curry you eat Curry Kebab
yeah all this stuff you go to our Muslim
countries you go and get yourself T to
look like us and then you come here
complain about us we got the recipe your
recipe of disaster we got the recipe for
the curry mate we don't need you you got
the recipe of the curry yeah and we can
make it better than you leave the curry
to the than you trust me not are better
you know it's funny I used to work in a
FR can make a curry better I used to I
used to work in a balii restaurant yeah
and these racist people like him would
come and they would have their vindoo
they would love
they love it and then they'll go and say
are you pis are you n are you this or
that listen get the hatred out of your
heart we're not here to take hat I love
my people I'm not I don't care about I
don't hate you just got no interest
you're only you're only saying that now
I believe if you had the power you'll
kill me no no yes yes yes because God I
I believe if you had the power because
you're a Son of God and God doesn't want
me to kill I'm not the son I'm not the
Son of God actually it does if you read
your Bible your Bible tell you clearly
what to do with me no yes it does
Philistines Canaanites okay good so
you're justifying The Killing so do you
condemn Israel for killing is righteous
if God says so okay so I do you condemn
the killing of Palestinian kids in
Israel no in in Palestine you don't cuz
in war children die okay good so but do
you condone that what do you think
that's Justified War have you heard this
phrase All is fair in Love and War so so
basically this is so you remember guys I
had a conversation with other guy Ryan
and I said that their ideology is the
same and he said not really die in Wars
okay do you condemn the do you condemn
AEL in the second world war we leveled
German cities killing thousands of women
and children and how how does that make
it right because they were trying to
destroy us okay one second how does that
you did it to Nagasaki trying to destroy
Israel no Israel why wouldn't they
defend themselves guys guys look at this
logic here you don't want us here
because you believe that we are building
mosques but you are the same people
defending Israel when they have taken a
look check this out to Israel we we ow
nothing you're their puppets bro you're
their little do
listen don't want to here you're
agitated because we're here they're
doing very America is in charge mate
believe let me I know that I know that
not in charge United States of is Israel
going to have power over America United
States of Israel not States yeah look
here there you have you you are agitated
one second brother you are so one second
I don't care where he is it's probably
German yeah I know I know now guys he
he's agitated cuz we Muslims are in this
land now imagine if we now imagine if I
kick you okay no imagine I KCK house I I
never want to leave you that's why to
leave the country you leave so now I
leave yes you leave so someone is coming
to my is telling me to leave my exactly
yes it'll be a better place now if I
came guys your country is in Ruins if I
yes by you guys thank you very much yes
you guys thank you if I came and kicked
you out from your house what would you
do you really don't like me what if I
came and kicked you out from your house
I don't make any excuse give you they
defend Israel finish him he's already
finished
anyway that's what I'm going to say I
would I hope you come to guidance and
clear yourself to any your you just
listen to other people anyways anyways
let him go as you can see guys this is
where this is where hatred comes from
yeah as you can see he's he's he's he's
an absolute biger he doesn't want to TW
he's here saying leave the country these
are the individuals that are on the
street if he if he had the power trust
me he will kill us yes yeah 100% anyway
thank you thanks for exposing thanks for
exposing %